yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah if I'm tracking everything
correctly this will be the video for new
years day I hope all of you had a good
start to the new year and I wish all of
your good happy 2017 okay let's see what
we can do in this game I have to say
that I did not upload the original New
Year's Day video that I recorded a
couple of minutes ago because i played
against damn obvious cheetah and I
really didn't want to upload such a
video and start then do a year yeah with
the cheetah video I mean it was really
that would have been a really bad way to
start of start of this this new new year
so let's play demo matata here
interesting play about him he tries to
ya fight for squares for his nights just
play a sex it's not necessarily terrible
terrible for me I mean and now I cannot
take what what was I thinking okay okay
not so good I wanted to originally take
but it doesn't make any sense okay so
yeah here maybe I can place your form
yeah let's do it try to be aggressive
not allow him to block everything that's
the good news I wanted to and I will
still do that I'm bringing the bishop
around to be six that was one point of
c4 but now as the position unfolded I
probably would have much preferred to
have the other work on c8 so that I have
f5 available anyway we'll see i don't
think this is that bad pieces look
reasonably active maybe just queen to
see several it's not so bad now it's
just covering it's not exactly a
difficult move to spot but I still fail
to see it um okay yeah I'd like to have
a five and play that I should have taken
the other look probably anyway when I
went here maybe still here it looked
fairly normal anyway i'm preparing f5
she doesn't really huh what's going on
here I can do this now right let's do
this first see five years i'm taking us
it's got a very unstable see file ok and
a five for a 40 f five by five is good
huh why not it looks at this isn't that
screams to be played in a way so i take
here
it will take it looks terribly
overloaded the whole position let's do
this for a for a form let's do this and
here we've got a couple of things going
in I can also just take and play play
the Queen somewhere it's not extremely
convincing though
bit unsure what to do here it's
certainly not bad for me but I don't
quite see a really great continuation so
let's play normal continuations and or
something it shouldn't be bad
thought this should be quite okay not
sure if it was it was probably not the
best possible way to play with any way i
can take here check takes it to the
we've been taking this looks wrong
anyway check not much time
[Music]
yeah i mean this probably I know am i
okay here i'm also i have Queen takes a
tool also as an idea like Queen takes e4
I can take I can take also with look I
don't know doesn't feel dangerous this
one okay right now I want to have to a
lot I mean really a lot check time or
date not sure if that was best but it
feels easy to play okay can I do this a
little bit of it suks long hear your
voice is not ideal but I kind of have to
now
[Music]
check okay check probably it wrong it's
that's a little from this from this
position actually draw our third I can
still play a couple of rooms here you
can do not much but there are chamfered
draw Alfred drum Arthur on Jared Rosen
good that must have been a very good
position at one point like here black
should really win a little bit later at
least after f500 does not agree that I'm
quite surprised about this looks like
complete crap for white and it's just a
slight advantage amazingly okay five was
correct I will cream shakes after this
is a funny one check the test stuff that
I should see I mean it's not very
difficult like it's better o Queen
urchin yeah this was kind of normal
which maybe maybe just not carry enough
rookie to okay that's more precise check
yeah I was also looking at the clock a
little but ya know thinking okay let's
play something where you can place
quickmover check our King f6 is stronger
Oh a lot stronger and then that should
that should probably win yeah yeah this
is not another check now at least the
draw the start of side of the new year
would be would have been awkward to have
a loss thanks for watching guys bye bye